[Music]
you know one of the secrets to having
strawberries and be able to harvest them
organically isn't that you have to use
pesticides but you have to keep up on
processing your crop as you can see here
this is my strawberry bed and there's
still a lot of strawberries in here I've
picked all these strawberries in the
last couple minutes and there's still a
lot to be had but what happens with a
strawberry bed is you get a lot of these
little sow bugs and a lot of other
little guys in there and you have to
pick them before the bugs get started on
them I pick them when they're just ripe
tomorrow all these will be - right so -
another day but if you let them sit for
just a little bit too long you'll start
getting a little bug bites all over them
from the the sow bugs also if you can
kind of pull them up as you're doing the
ones that are still white pull them up
so that they're not sitting right on the
ground that helps a lot and if they're
too ripe like this one right here
actually I just I just throw them back
on the ground let the sow bugs have them
I'd be nice to be able to just come in
here and poison them and put all kinds
of stuff in here but I like I'd like to
be able to just take a fresh strawberry
right from the patch I know there's no
poison in there when I start picking
[Music]
so there's still good bachelor
strawberries in here I've been getting
from this bed that's four feet wide by
12 feet long I've been getting at least
one the two baskets of strawberries
every day and I usually eat them as I
pick them but strawberry pass has got to
get one
[Music]